la majorité de ce que l'on voit pousser
dans les chansons des cultures annuelles
le maïs et le soya et céréales comme le
blé et les plantes pérennes celles qui
survivent pendant plusieurs années n'ont
plus la cote
on n'a qu'à penser à toutes les plantes
qui composent le foin qu'on donne aux
animaux comme la luzerne par exemple
pourtant ces cultures sont d'excellentes
alliés pour améliorer la santé du sol et
leur demande est en forte croissance
[Musique]
dans les champs de la ferme ou valbois
en estrie la première coupe de foin est
réglé au quart de tour faucheuse faneuse
râteau vont et viennent sans relâche
avec près de 1000 hectares de plantes
fourragères en culture il y encore
beaucoup de travail à faire le foin est
jeune très feuillus et d'un beau vert
ici aucun signe de sécheresse le fonds
est beau et de quelle taille fourni on
est très heureux pour l'instant ça
s'enligne bien pour le reste de la
saison à la firme valbois le fouet et
récolté très tôt en saison
la quantité de balle produite est donc
un peu moins importante mais ce foin
primeur sans déchets ni additifs et
recherché par les clients nous savons
tout aux états unis on sait qu aux
etats-unis à des chevaux loire plusieurs
millions par les producteurs sont très
fiers les animaux ça sert avant tout les
bastons floride miami tout dans ce
coin-là à 120 km de quoi tiko dans ce
champ de la montérégie la première coupe
de foin s'annoncent plus décevante à la
date où en est le fond il devra mener
presque aux épaules et j'ai de la misère
à l'avoir au genou ça s'annonce une
récolte très moyenne pour ce thème
depuis trois ans la culture des plantes
fourragères et laborieuse pour luc
normandin l'un des plus importants
commerçants de foin au québec manque de
couverts de neige gèle et mortalité en
hiver chaleur et sécheresse l'été la
météo fait des siennes
loin de se décourager luc normandin il
voit plutôt une opportunité comme
commerçant points
c'est une opportunité parce qu'il va
voir plein gens qui vont manquer tron
pour garnir ses immenses entrepôts
il compte sur tout un réseau de
producteurs de plantes fourragères à
travers le pays
en diversifiant les emplacements
production luc normandin s'assure de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins de ses
clients en europe au moyen orient et aux
états unis
on a des contacts un peu partout dans
toutes les provinces pour acheter soins
aux endroits où ayant des bonnes
conditions pour le projet et qui veulent
nous vendre
valérie poulin et luc normandin deux
anciens producteurs de lait converti à
la culture des plantes fourragères ont
bâti des entreprises de commerce de foix
prospère on est un peu comme astérix et
obélix ici à sam 7 points donc on passe
pour tous mais on est le royaume pour le
vendre au québec la culture du foin est
la plus grande en importance en termes
de superficie mais les superficies qui
lui sont consacrés sont en baisse depuis
les années 80 une diminution d'environ
25 pour ça pourquoi
d'abord parce que le cheptel laitier et
le nombre de producteurs laitiers et de
vaches de boucherie ont diminué les
producteurs agricoles se sont aussi
tournés vers des cultures plus simple et
lucratives comme le maïs et le soya
si bien qu'aujourd'hui le foin à vendre
est souvent un surplus produits à la
ferme dont la qualité laisse à désirer
mais cultiver le foin pour en faire le
commerce demande beaucoup de travail
à commencer par l'analyse des sols cela
permet de fertiliser adéquatement les
plantes fourragères
les analyses de sol sont primordiales
lachaud l'engrais c'est vraiment c'est
très important c'est comme nourrir une
main j'essaye de l'eau se soit évadée
père et il faut aussi savoir naviguer à
travers les extrêmes climatiques avoir
l'oeil sur les radars météo
car l'élément clé dans le commerce du
foin c'est un foin sec pour les marchés
d'exportation le taux d'humidité doit
être de 12% au moins
difficile au québec de faire sécher le
foin au chat et si la récolte est trop
humide le foin risque de surchauffe et
ou de moisir on a réussi à trouver une
façon de sécher le foin c'est ce qui
nous démarque et c'est ce qui nous
démarque encore luc normandin a inventé
son propre modèle de séchoirs une
fournaise à granules produit de la
chaleur
la chaleur et l'air sont poussés vers le
faux plancher d'une remorque de camion
et circule à travers le foin entreposés
dans la remorque en 24 à 36 heures
le foin atteint le taux d'humidité
optimale
les propriétaires de la ferme balboa ont
investi eux aussi dans un séchoir et un
parc de machinerie spécialisée
on ne vendait que des accumulateurs on
est rendu avec des grappins on est rendu
avec plateau pour charger les vendre
donc t il faut s'adapter c'est la
technologie comme les célèbres évolue
constamment aussi la question
d'optimiser le transport à l'étranger et
d'augmenter la densité des balles de
foin nord fouet s'est doté d'un système
de transformation
donc on s'est acheté de l'équipement
pourrait dépendre de compresser le foin
plus de rendre partout dans le monde
puis après le monde la demande est forte
c'est facile devant du beauf la culture
des plantes fourragères et pérenne vient
donc avec son lot de défis mais elle
comporte aussi d'énormes avantages sur
le plan environnemental les pentes
fourragères comme un gibier
régulièrement elles sont généreuses
parce qu'elles ont amélioré la structure
des sols elles ont aussi apporté aux
magazines et des éléments fertilisants
elles ont créé des ports pour que le ce
thème race mais avec plus profondément
on vaut aussi avec ses racines l'accent
sur du très long terme augmenter le
niveau de carbone de matières organiques
massol et puisqu'elles couvrent le sol
365 jours par année
les plantes pérennes limite l'érosion
des sols malgré tout ce potentiel les
producteurs agricoles ont des réticences
à les intégrer dans leur culture
oui peut-être un petit peu plus défi
quand les la sécheresse est présente
mais on a d'autres alternatives devrait
on a d'autres possibilités faire des
semis plus à l'automne pour mieux
réussir nos implantations ça c'est des
choses qu'on est en train de regarder on
a des nouveaux cultivars qui vont aussi
à être disponible dans pas grand temps
[Musique]
annick la salle fait justement partie
d'un petit groupe de chercheurs qui
développent de nouveaux cultivars plus
performant et mieux adapté aux extrêmes
climatiques ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est surtout au niveau de la lutte
jaffiol des graminées qui sont plus
sensibles à la sécheresse dans ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est briser leur
dormance qui est causé par les hautes
températures
à la ferme expérimentale de
saint-augustin-de-desmaures elle planche
aussi sur l'amélioration génétique de la
luzerne
on essaie d'augmenter la tolérance au
froid la tolérance aussi aux maladies
printanière sur tous les malades du
reste nerfs avec les changements
climatiques 100 kg et qui sont déjà
arrivés on a des printemps très pluvieux
très humide non plus maladie aux racines
en obtenant plus présente
l'amélioration génétique des plantes
fourragères est un processus de
pollinisation croisée qui nécessite de
10 à 20 ans d'efforts
dans cette parcelle expérimentale où on
essaie d'augmenter la saison de
croissance de la luzerne des résultats
sont encourageants
donc on peut voir ici des plans qui sont
marc de la soixante dix la population de
base comparativement la population
améliorer ou il ya qu'elle n'a pas de
mortalité
donc ça pour vous c'est une belle russe
ça c'est très prometteur pour moi
d'autant plus prometteur que les plantes
fourragères sont adaptés aux régions
nordiques et pourrait valoriser des
terres en friche
ça va nous permettre d'avoir une banque
de fourrage qui va pouvoir pallier à ces
manques dans les différentes régions
de nouvelles variétés de plantes
pérennes apparaissent aussi dans les
champs depuis quelques années comme
cette graminée qui fait près de deux
mètres de haut
le panic érigé
l'entreprise dans les truies spécialisé
dans les sapins de noël s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré en 2013 et compte aujourd'hui
50 hectares de panic érigé la
biodiversité qui est sacré comme ça on
est très content et en plus on
al'avantage d'avoir moins de mauvaises
marchant on est on utilise moins de
produits chimiques
donc c'est beaucoup davantage pour nous
on est très content avec le paillis de
panic érigé est utilisé comme couvre-sol
dans la pépinière de sapins il est moins
acide et moins coûteux que le paillis de
cèdre traditionnelle et réduit les
besoins en irrigation
il est aussi vendue comme litière pour
les porcheries servi dans la ration des
vaches laitières ou employés en
production maraîchère
bref les vertus des plantes pérennes et
fourragères sont largement documenté la
demande est grande
les prix sont intéressants se passer
pour convaincre les gens de prendre une
fois la culture du foin qui a contribué
à façonner le paysage rural du québec a
un grand potentiel mais le développement
de la filière se fait attendre
[Musique]